تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لطيف لطفل خطف الانظار خلال مباراه
كره قدم في الجزائر وذلك لحرصه على عدم
تاخير صلاته حيث وجد مكانا لنفسه وسط
المدرجات ليؤدي الصلاه
[موسيقى]
تداولت صفحات على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو قالت انه لنيزك مره في سماء
مدينه شماليه الجزائر واظهر الفيديو ما
يشبه كره مضيئه تمر بسرعه في السماء ليلا
وبحسب وسائل اعلام محليه ومركزي علم الفلك
الجزائري اتضح ان الفيديو المتداول منشور
عام 2015 ضمن تقرير اخباري للتلفزيون
الارجنتيني
تعرض ضابط متطوع من شرطه لوس انجلوس
الامريكيه لهجوم مروع من قبل سربي نحل
غاضب تكاتل عليه وانهالا بلدعه واسقطه
ارضا وتم نقل الضابط المصاب الى المستشفى
لتلقي العلاج
[موسيقى]
نشطون على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صورا
تظهر هاله تحيط بالشمس في مناطق مختلفه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ما اثارت دهشه
واعجاب السكان وفسر المتخصص بعلم الفلك
ملهم هندي هذه الظاهره طبقات الجو العليا
في تلك المناطق كانت مشبعه بالرطوبه ما
ادى الى انكسار الضوء الى انكسار الضوء
وظهور الهاله الساحره حول الشمس
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات